I saw you spying on me earlier
[Music]
see you tomorrow good
[Music]
who moves out in the middle of the night
nothing strange about it she wanted to
leave how does that not make sense I
don't understand why she didn't tell me
maybe she didn't like you maybe she
knows you're poor and haven't paid your
rent founder some kind of code or like
secret message in her department son it
means to stay quiet our world is filled
with codes subliminal messages from
Silver Lake to the Hollywood else could
any of this be connected to Sarah I knew
this girl there's a message in the music
[Music]
[Applause]
assume that this information is what
we're told it is maybe there are people
out there who are more important than us
powerful communicating things in the
world that are meant for only them but
not for us
yeah oh you think that's weird a little
welcome to purgatory good to be here
you're living in a carnival
hoping to win a prize what are you gonna
win
under the silver leg
you